oh how a married life geniu you guys  it's the best I feel like everyone  should get married and seriously so much  fun I'm having a blast  we're just enjoying getting together in  LA yeah love is great love is amazing  spread it all around so new season of  Dancing with the Stars here enough  people are stoked  how is Vaughn shaping up Vaughn actually  you guys he's thinking up things so  quick he really is he's very cocky he's  an amazing student so of course it's the  first season without Derek in a long  long time how much you guys gonna miss  having him on that show  Derek is a big part of the show you know  he's been around for a long time he's  like he's one of the main people on the  show so to have him gone I mean it's  gonna be weird honestly it's gonna be  it's gonna feel like we're missing  someone always which we are but it's  just gonna feel weird but I just hope  them the best and he'll be missed for  sure